son mobile de france inter françois
bayrou bonjour on joue et merci d'être
un autre micro ce matin on va parler
dans quelques instants de l'industrie en
france de la dette publique de la
proportionnelle mais quelques mots pour
commencer sur le moment étrange dans
lequel on se trouve
la france sera t-elle à nouveau confinés
dans quelques jours les signaux envoyés
par les deux têtes de l'exécutif sont
contradictoires et flou on a du mal à
comprendre matignon 10 et hier matin des
décisions importantes seront prises
cette semaine quelques heures plus tard
l'elysée expliqué que rien n'était acté
vous même avait déclaré qu'un pays ne
peut pas vivre sous cloche
est ce à dire françois bayrou qu'il faut
tout faire pour éviter un recond
finement en tout cas j'approuve tout ce
que le président de la république l
exécutif ont pour éviter leur
confinement
je sais très bien que si on ceci on se
limitait au strict point de vue
épidémiologique probablement le plus
efficace serait en effet de reconfirmer
de tour fermé de tout mettre sous cloche
comme vous le rappeliez moi je crois au
contraire que la recherche d' équilibre
qui est le qui est la mission des
gouvernants c'est que on freine autant
possible l'épidémie mais qu' on laisse
ouverts ce qui est essentiel et ce qui
est essentiel à la caisse qui est
essentiel c'est les écoles c'est
essentiellement parce que ainsi c'est ça
permet d'avoir au
aux parents ou aux maires le plus
souvent aux mères de famille le plus
souvent ça permet d'avoir une vie qui
soit une vie à la fois sociale et
familiale et ce qui pour moi est
essentiel et je sais très bien que c'est
difficile il faut penser aux universités
parce que cet âge là entre 18 et 25 ans
c'est un âge qui est moins facile qu'on
ne le croit quand on a dépassé cet âge
ce n'est pas un âge où tout va de soi et
dans la formation de la personnalité
la rencontre avec l'autre les autres les
autres de son âge les enseignants c'est
absolument vital le être refermée dans
une cité universitaire ou dans un
appartement ou chez soi et ne pas en
sortir
à cet âge là entre 18 et 25 ans c'est
important et je crois qu'on pourrait
qu'on pourrait à la fois recherché une
ouverture et une communication et une
formation pour que ils comprennent que
on peut éviter d'être porteurs du virus
et de contaminer ses proches ce qu'on
aime s'affaler ouais mais s'il le
fallait pensez vous que nous aurions
collectivement la force d'un troisième
confinement comment sentez-vous le pays
françois bayrou on entre dans cette
deuxième année de l'épidémie on entend
comme vous le disiez tous les jours les
médecins nous parler de ces chiffres qui
font peur
est-ce que vous ressentez chez les
français la lassitude une fatigue morale
une grande fatigue mentale aussi ce que
tout ça vous inquiète plongée j'ai un
point de vue qui va vous paraître
surprenant moi j'ai une certitude c'est
qu'on va s'en sortir on s'est sorti de
guerre absolument terrible avec des
millions de morts et dieu sait que ça a
été pour le pays
une saignée séculaire on va se sortir de
cette épidémie
c'est un pays qui a en lui des
ressources des forces une capacité une
c'est vrai mais vous la sentez la
lassitude
oui bien sûr on sent la lassitude
comment comment serait-il autrement
bien sûr on sent plus que la lassitude
le le sentiment d'inquiétude c'est que
on ne voit pas comment on peut trouver
une issue et pour moi cette issue elle
est très claire c'est si on vérifie que
le vaccin est efficace et qu'il est sûre
alors c'est la vaccination qui est la
sortie de la crise vous n'êtes pas sûr
qu'il soit efficace et suis je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est prouvé qu'il est
sur combien de temps dure son efficacité
on sait pas parce que il commence à être
et donc le la vaccination est un horizon
pour l'ouverture et pour l'ouverture de
la vie scolaire universitaire
professionnel et culturel une question
françois bayrou sur les vaccins
disponibles en ce début d'année
aucun est français celui de sanofi est
retardée jusqu'à la fin de l'année hier
pasteur annoncé l'abandon du vaccin sur
lequel l'institut travaille et qu'est ce
que ça dit fondamentalement de l'état de
la recherche française est ce un signe
du déclassement de notre pays dans la
recherche mondiale
oui je ne crois pas qu'on puisse le dire
comme ça puisque le président de modern
à l'un des deux laboratoires qui fournit
ces vaccins de cette technologie
nouvelle qui est la rn messager ce
président est français oui mais via vos
états unis et ses fonds c est bien vous
voyez nous avons là une question que
nous ne pouvons pas éluder ce n'est pas
possible que nos chercheurs que les plus
brillants de nos chercheurs et on le
voit naturellement médecine on le voit
en économie on le voit les plus
brillants de nos chercheurs sont aspirés
par le système américain
et bien c'est le signe d'une comment
dirais-je d'un déclassement d'un
déclassement du pays vous avez raison et
ce déclassement là est inacceptable
c'est pourquoi alors il faut que nous
construisions notre notre action
publique y compris en matière de
recherche comme les américains l'ont
fait ils ont construit il ya déjà des
décennies d une organisation qui permet
de repérer la recherche essentiels pour
l'avenir
ça veut dire de l'argent le commissaire
au plan que vous êtes vous savez bien
qu'il parte c'est de lire ce qu'il y a
plus d'argent ça y est l'argent je vais
vous dire c'est de l'argent bien placé
oui c'est de nous avons la chance de
vivre dans un moment où on peut
précisément emprunter pour l'essentiel
emprunter pour préparer l'avenir et moi
qui me suis préoccupé de la dette toute
ma vie on y va cet investissement est
nécessaire on y va sur la lettre dans un
instant mais une autre question qui vous
tient à coeur l'industrie vous avez dit
en tant que commissaire au plan la
france doit avoir pour objectif de
remonter la part de l'industrie à 17% du
pib' aujourd'hui elle est entre 10 et
12% à 12 ou et il faut qu'elles
remontent à 10 7% du pib d'ici cinq ans
comment fait-on concrètement pour
réindustrialiser la france c'est le
travail d'une réflexion comme c'est ma
mission c'est de donner des repères et
je me dis que 1 % par an d'augmentation
ce qui en cinq ans fait en effet de
l'ordre de 5%
ça doit être un objectif collectif que
nous sommes capables de prendre le
quand on voit ce qu'elle a été le la
dérive au travers des décennies c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui que je dis ça j'ai
fait une campagne présidentielle sur le
produire en france et à l'époque c'était
l'objet de quolibets comme comme si ça
n'existait pas nous avons besoin de
reconstruire notre place dans l'économie
mondiale ce qui donne à la france une
obligation qui est plus importante plus
forte que celle de nos voisins nous nous
avons non seulement besoin de sauver et
soutenir notre industrie mais de la
promouvoir pour et il se trouve que ce
que nous rappelions ensemble on peut
aujourd'hui mobiliser des
investissements qu'on ne pouvait pas
mobilisés hier et il se trouve qu'en
plus c'est un tournant de la production
mondiale
ça nous offre une chance françois bayrou
vous le disiez en parlant de la dette
quand on se souvient de 2012 campagne
présidentielle vous étiez le candidat
2007 et 2007 même pardon est
effectivement excusez moi vous étiez le
le candidat qui défend des la bonne
gestion des finances publiques vous
mettiez en garde contre les déficits
publics la dette en disant qu'il n'était
pas possible de léguer tout ça aux
générations futures
là aujourd'hui 2021 la dette de la
france s'élève à 120 % du pib' faut-il
selon vous arrêter la politique du quoi
qu'il en coûte qui a été décrétée par le
président de la république au début de
l'épidémie de covin c'est une question
en face de laquelle il faut avoir les
yeux ouverts
on ne peut pas emprunter pour tout et
n'importe quoi mais on doit emprunter
parce que nous sommes dans une économie
de guerre
quand il ya la guerre personne se pose
la question on est obligé d'acheter des
avions d
des blindés de des navires faire ce
qu'il faut parce que c'est la vie du
pays qui est en jeu
là c'est la vie du pays qui est en jeu
et il faut ajouter que cette menace sur
la vie du pays
personne n'est responsable personnes il
n'est pas de de responsabilité ni
individuelles ni collective à la
mutation d'un virus et donc on est
obligé d'y faire face et par chance
extraordinaire puisque nous avons
maintenant la puissance de la banque
centrale européenne pour nous aider on
peut le faire sans grever exagérément
l'avenir à condition de focaliser la
dépense publique sur ce sujet du coc
vide et de ne pas laisser entrer toutes
les dépenses de fonctionnement par
exemple de nos de notre organisation et
quand c'est le cas c'est une tentation
vous voyez bien je vais faire dans les
jours qui viennent une communication sur
ce sujet pour aider à la réflexion du
pays sur la dette
je pense qu'il est très important de
isolé cantonner les dépenses qui sont
celles de réponses précises aux cabinets
quelles sont les dépenses par exemple
inefficace qu'on fait en ce moment où
qu'on serait tenté de faire je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas la prétention de de désigner
tel ou tel
action du gouvernement pour ça il ya le
gouvernement ya la cour des comptes il
ya un mois je
j'ai l'âge et la volonté de définir une
stratégie pour que les français
comprennent ou est une réponse aux
questions qui se posaient une question
très simple ils disent mais d'où vient
cet argent et comment ça se fait que
hier ça n'était pas possible et que la
dévorant vous le rappeliez et que
aujourd'hui c'est possible alors on
pouvait emprunter yari avait pas
d'argent magique et aujourd'hui on peut
grever les dépenses publiques de 120 %
précisément parce que c'est une économie
de guerre ce que nous traversons ce que
la planète entière traverse en tout cas
ce que l'occident traverse tout entier
c'est une épreuve à laquelle il faut que
nous répondions sans aucune sans aucune
timidité
certains disent que cette dette covin ne
sera jamais remboursé c'est le cas
d'arnaud montebourg qui dit comment
rembourser 500 milliards de dette en
plus on ne pourra pas le faire sont des
jacqueries et des révoltes il demande à
la bce à la banque centrale européenne
dont vous parlez de racheter ses dettes
qu vide
est ce que vous pensez d'abord c'est ce
qu'elle fait on peut pas demander à la
bce comme une exigence ce qui est en
réalité son action de tous les jours
mais moi je ne suis pas pour que on est
là désinvolture de dire c'est une dette
dans ton se moquera parce que si c'était
le cas alors avec certitude
on sait que personne ne nous prêtera
plus jamais ni la bce ni clip soit
d'autre en revanche je suis favorable -
à ce qu'il y ait ce qu'on appelle quand
on achète une maison un différé
d'amortissement
c'est à dire qu'on dise voilà c'est une
dette dont nous prenons acte
mais nous allons prendre dix ans pour
redresser le pays et c'est à ce moment
là que sur une longue période
l'argent à 0 % c'est une chance parce
que ça permet de programmer dans le
temps à longue distance les
remboursements et vous voyez que si on a
une stratégie comme ça isolé cantonné
définir la dette qu'ovide avoir un
différé d'amortissement et un
remboursement sur longue distance à leur
tout d'un coup on devient des citoyens
qui savons
vont qui savent où ils vont avant
d'aller au standard une question sur
cette étude que publie l ong oxfam
hier montrant que les plus riches
ressorte encore plus riche de la crise
du coc vider les pauvres encore plus
pauvres pour le dire aussi simplement
que ça les plus pauvres devront attendre
dix ans avant de retrouver le niveau de
vie d'avant la pandémie là où les plus
riches ont mis en substance dix mois ne
pensez-vous pas françois bayrou que les
plus riches devraient contribuer
davantage dans ce contexte qu'une
appelons la comme ça qu'une taxe
qu'ovide une participation
exceptionnelle serait bienvenu alors
c'est plus compliqué encore et peut-être
plus inquiétant je ne sais pas comment
on peut dire que on ne le décrit dans
dans cette interrogation l'argent à 0 %
c'est formidable pour soutenir un pays
mais c'est une aubaine extraordinaire
pour ceux qui ont la surface financière
de pouvoir envisager de très gros
investissements
vous faites un investissement dont vous
attendez qu'il vous rapporte 2 % par an
et on vous prête de l'argent à 0%
cadeaux alors ça c'est pour ça que les
plus riches s'enrichissent ça que je
pense c'est pour ça que s'il y avait
aujourd'hui on le dit pas assez c'est
une aubaine pour certaines grandes
entreprises
en tout cas il y a là un sujet de
réflexion que nous pouvons aborder et
c'est vrai que nous sommes dans un monde
déséquilibré mais nous serions dans un
monde bien plus déséquilibré si nous
n'avions pas cette possibilité de
dépenser pour soutenir des entreprises
en péril les familles fait pour
sénégalais qu'est ce que vous proposez
est-ce qu'il faut une taxe est si
exceptionnelle des plus riches - non je
pense qu'il est trop tôt pour qu'on pour
qu'on réponde à cette question et
d'ailleurs personne ne répond comme vous
l'avez observé au travers de la planète
je suis intéressé de voir ce que va
faire le nouveau président américain sur
ce sujet parce que comme vous savez le
foyer de incandescent de l'économie du
monde sait les états unis et la banque
centrale qui est enquis et en avant qui
est qui qui ouvre le chemin c'est la
banque centrale américaine je suis
intéressé de savoir ce que ce que le
parti démocrate américain va faire allez
on file au standard on nous attend
pierre pierre qui nous appellent de
versailles bonjour et bienvenue oui
bonjour à tous c'est au président du
modem que je vais m'adresser
le candidat macro avait promis
instauration de proportionnelle pour les
prochaines législatives
est ce que le vous pensez que le
président de l'achru tiendrai cette
promesse
merci pierre pour cette question
monsieur le président du modem françois
bayrou répond d'abord vous avez raison
de considérer que cette question est une
question essentielle
ça ne paraît pas dans les conversations
de bistrot il est rare qu'on aborde de
bissau d'abord ya bien plus triste dans
les conversations familière on joue pas
beaucoup de la proportionnelle à suzuka
et pourtant c'est une question
essentielle nous vivons et d'ailleurs
c'est pas par hasard que et le président
actuel et son prédécesseur et son entée
prédécesseurs avaient tous posé cette
question et pour les deux derniers
s'étaient engagés formellement à changer
le mode de souris semble l'abandonner
également oui mais moi je ne je ne
baisse pas les bras
moi je trouve que quand on a pris un
engagement et koné devant un sujet
essentiel
alors il faut que les responsables
publics fassent face à leurs obligations
pourquoi c'est important vous voyez bien
à quel point le parlement deux jours en
jours et de plus en plus déconsidérés en
tout cas les français n'écoutent plus ce
qui s'y passe pourquoi
parce que la composition du parlement
avec l'hégémonie d'un seul parti
successivement l'ump le parti socialiste
en marge la majorité actuelle est
tellement déconnectés de la réalité du
pays que un très grand nombre de
citoyens s'en détournent
vous avez des forces politiques on peut
ne pas les aimer
c'est ce que dit christophe castaner par
exemple il dit je ne veux pas faire
entrer sans député rn à l'assemblée
nationale selon lui répondent avoir de
cette formule est une formule qui ne
correspond pas à une pensée équilibrer
ses pales c'est pas les députés qu on
fait entrer à l'assemblée nationale
c'est la représentation des électeurs
il y aurait pas de député s'ils avaient
pas d'électeurs et dire ces électeurs là
me plaisent je les prends ses amis
généralement ou les proches de ses amis
ces électeurs là ne me plaisent pas et
donc je les écarte de la représentation
nationale
pour moi c'est une faute de raisonnement
et pendant ce temps le pire c'est qu'on
invente des comités tirés au sort dont
on ne connaît pas les membres dont on ne
connaît pas les idées doit-on à la
mévente et un citoyen entre autres mais
iliad a plein dont on ne connaît pas les
idées et on les met sur le même pied que
la représentation nationale
parlementaire mais vous voyez bien qu'il
ya un déséquilibre est incroyable alors
pourquoi on doit pour moi je cette idée
vous allez vous l'avez développé
plusieurs fois et bien je vais des
années avec emmanuel macron et là il
vous dit je sais on en croit la une du
figaro c'est la une ce matin emmanuel
macron enterre la proportionnelle mais à
l'intérieur
j'essaie d'apporter une réponse
si je tombe on a tourné la page et
quatre pages consacrées à ce sujet là et
malheureusement ces noms donc
excusez moi l'idée que des courants
politiques qui représente un français
sur quatre qui sont des courants
politiques majeures ça nous est arrivé
vers plusieurs d'entre nous est arrivé à
jean luc mélenchon ça m'est arrivé à moi
en 2007 c'est arrivé à marine le pen qui
était elle au deuxième tour cette fois
ci eh bien il est malsain et nuisible
pour le débat démocratique que c'est me
dizaines de millions de français ne soit
pas représenté mme en fait si si un
problème de délais parce que la fin du
quinquennat wii 2 ou suggérés à et moi
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de problème de
délais et les constitutionnalistes
peuvent apporter toutes les réponses
mais de deux choses l'une ou bien on
choisit la voie parlementaire il ya rien
de plus simple que de voter une loi et
c'est à la seule discrétion de
l'assemblée nationale ou bien si on a
des doutes et des interrogations
on consulte les français il ya une
disposition dans la constitution qui
permet de poser aux français une
question simple sur un texte simple un
référendum donc sur la proportionnelle
c'est ce que vous dites mais l'avait
référendum il y aura il devrait y avoir
si on en croit mais on peut poser
plusieurs questions inscrire
l'environnement la naissance à lorient
demandant la constitution peut poser
plusieurs questions dans le même
référendum
voyez il nous manque un instrument
démocratique que les suisses ont par
exemple et qui aide beaucoup à la vie
démocratique de la suisse c'est de
pouvoir interroger les citoyens votent à
sur des questions qui sont des questions
de de leur vie en commun ils ont bien le
droit de s'exprimer
donc vous pensez pas pardon d'être un
peu brutal mais vous pensez pas que vous
rêvez encore de faire passer la
proportionnelle avant la fin du bio là
si je rêve je trouve que le combat assis
sur un rêve
ou en tout cas sur un idéal ou sur un
projet rassembleur
c'est un bon combat on a besoin de
changer le mode de gouvernement de la
france l'hégémonie d'un seul parti ça
marche pas et on voit bien on n'a pas pu
faire passer des réformes et donc je
vous dites vous même que vous voyez bien
la réforme des retraites elle n'est pas
passée en fin dé des très grands sujets
sur lesquels nous sommes engagés alors
il faut penser imaginer un changement
des méthodes de gouvernement dans un
pays où elle ne marche plus sur
l'application d'un ter pascal vous pose
la question suivante
emmanuel macron a dit que la france
était 66 millions de procureur c'est sur
le l'épidémie de covile je trouve ça
agressif et condescendant dit pascal ont
fait des efforts depuis un an et il nous
balance ça ça n'est pas bien
françois bayrou et je peux je pense que
le que la réaction
cette phrase a été comme assez souvent
épidermiquement très très vives
je pense que ce que le président de la
république voulait dire et il a raison à
mes yeux de le dire c'est qu'on entre
dans un seco n'entre dans un dans un
moment où tout le monde dénonce tout le
monde
la dénonciation devient une espèce de
sport national